you may have already noticed that the
mets have hats on
uh honoring first responders this is
september 11th that awful day
19 years ago today in the mets and i
believe the yankees too and their
doubleheader against the orioles are all
wearing caps honoring first responders
as we know chase is a four-pitch pitcher
he uses a fastball he had a very good
curveball last time out but he gave up
three home runs to the red sox in the
second inning in the past he's pitched
pretty well against the new york mets
chase anderson will get set to face
brandon nimmo to lead off
and a swing and a miss anderson battles
back to strike him out
with houston his first couple of years
in the big leagues and he hits a ground
ball to short should be an easy play for
espinal and chase anderson gets the meds
in order in the top of the first
brilliance of jacob degrom on display
his ninth start of the year three and
one with a
1.69 era the best in the national league
and guerrero with a fly ball to right
field this one is pretty well hit
and it's going to be off the wall
conforto could not make the catch
richie comes in to score guerrero's only
at first on the play but he does drive
in the first run of the night it's
conforto mis-timed his jump actually
took his eye off the ball
well there's one guriel goes down
looking and degrom gets the backward k
that's been eluding him two strikeouts
the inning now with first and second two
out andres jimenez coming up a little
bit out of character for
chase anderson
popped up shallow and left here comes
gorielle on a dead run reaches out goes
into the slide and he makes the catch
what a tremendous running grab by
lourdes goriel jr left his feet at the
right time went into a slide and he
scoops it right off the blades of grass
and michael conforto will now step in so
a golden opportunity here for the mets
to tie or go ahead
again the 3-2 from anderson and a
fastball that's drilled deep to center
field grichik on the run and is not
going to get there it's gone home run
michael conforto with a three-run shot
deep center field conforto's ninth home
run of the year and the mets take a 3-1
lead here in the top of the third inning
two outs and two on and three in for the
mets jeff mcneil left on left against
anthony kate
mcneal skies one toward the center you
can't see it grichik is confused now
season and it's too late it falls in as
a run scores jd davis comes home mcneal
gets a gift from the lighting at salem
field and it's a four to one match lead
so back to the top of the lineup for the
blue jays and kevin biggio
bishio swings and misses went too far on
that check swing that was a wicked
slider
it certainly was
five strikeouts
75 strikeouts now for degrom the most in
the national league
jacob degrom makes short work of randall
grichik he has retired seven straight he
has six strikeouts he's in control now
with a three-run lead
the bases are loaded for the mets nobody
out here in the fourth inning j.d davis
who loves to hit against left-handed
pitching
davis hammers this one but handled by
the shortstop as espinal throws to the
late chance and drops it and ramos is
safe oh my gosh what a mistake by danny
jensen who was a gold glove nominee in
the american league last year espinal
didn't catch it cleanly had to throw
home and jensen mishandles it dom smith
now steps in what a mess from the blue
jays in these last couple of innings
smith goes 3-0 and he goes way back
grant slam dominic smith and the mets
have busted it open
it is 9-1 as smith launches his eighth
home run of the year he now has a team
leading 36 runs batted in and the mets
are pouring it on the blue jays in
buffalo the 19th met to come to the
plate in the last two innings last time
the mets batted around twice
in back-to-back innings april 29 2018.
oh and it's going to be longer than that
ramos sends this one to the gap he's
going to unload the bases cano mcneal
jimenez all score on a three-run double
and wilson ramos has made it 12-1
right now as conforto goes the other way
guriel misses that one with a slide in
left that's going to bring home another
run as ramos scores it's 13-1 and on top
of toronto's poor pitching tonight their
defense has been a bit sloppy lourdes
guriel couldn't make that play one and
two the cap
on j.d davis
and he laces one that is a fair ball
down the left field line into the corner
goriel is giving chase conforto rounding
third he will head home it is now
14-1 new york jacob degrom has not had
to pitch much for the last hour or so
guerrero swings through the high
fastball strikeout number seven for
degrom tonight
there's a tip into the glove of ramos
degrom gets his eighth strikeout shaking
his head after a scoreless inning
all three of his pitches hasn't been as
sharp as you saw probably in the last
game
doesn't have to be
ariel gets a piece of it pops it up on
the infield so degrom won't get his
tenth strikeout but he does get a one
two three six to end his night
rookie will work to robinson canoe with
the bases full
and there's ball four so borucky comes
in walks in a run and it is now 15 to
one
neal chops one off the plate espinal
gets one out mcneal gets an rbi jd davis
coming home and now it's 16-1
wilson ramos goes after the first pitch
from giles he hammers it davis runs out
of room it's gone
wilson ramos has had a huge night
two doubles and now a home run and the
mets not done scoring they kick an extra
point to make it 17-1 watch for flying
baseballs is right
the buffalo roams in buffalo and with
this game out of hand and they don't
want to use any more
pitchers santiago espinal is going to
pitch the top of the ninth inning so how
about that
did he hit him he hit him as pearl
bailey said in the 1969
world series highlight film
it's a base hit here from jimenez
that's his first of the night it scores
alonso it's 18-1
blue jays down to their last out
joe panic strikes out the mets win 18-1
a total blowout in buffalo tonight